if you see a happiness curve on
subjective well-being it's actually like
a smiley face people are happiest when
they're like 10 years old and then they
go slow and steady down the value of
Despair is like 45 to 55 and then they
start to come up the other side once
they get into elderly and retirement age
one of the biggest things that they
attributed it to is that the things that
relationships and circumstances that
people used to deal with or suffer
through they literally didn't have time
for that they're like I only have 10
years left I don't have time for Susie
she's negative I think that if I am
going to be that way eventually I might
as well enjoy the benefits of making
those types of decisions now despite it
not being invoked